[Musica]
Elena a 16 anni e da grande vuole fare
la falegname quando lo dice tutti la
guardano strano
sennò invece gli anni ne ha 18 e tutte
le sacrosante sere va in discoteca
tranne la domenica perché invece va con
gli amici dietro la stazione ad avere
una mano senza tetto
Francesca e Luisa sono bellissima quando
mano nella mano si guardano negli occhi
e attraversano il corridoio della
presidenza
Edo Edo vuole scrivere delle lettere ai
detenuti o del carcere dove lavoro suo
papà perché così dice hanno qualcuno con
cui parlare del fuori
suo papà dice è molto orgoglioso di
questa idea
Lucia
farebbe solo abbracciare le persone che
stanno cercando di smettere con l'alcool
e lei invece di suo papà non parla mai
Buonasera buonasera invece sono Andrea e
di mestiere faccio il regista teatrale e
con la mia compagnia al teatro
dell'Argine sono un po' di anni che ci
stiamo divertendo Tra le altre cose a
immaginare progetti dove il teatro c'è
ma non si vede
negli ultimi due anni e mezzo abbiamo
lavorato a stretto contatto con più di
500 adolescenti dell'area metropolitana
bolognese sui temi dell'agenda 2030 lo
abbiamo fatto in un progetto che si
chiama politico poetico è un progetto
voluto dal Comune di Bologna e
finanziato per fortuna da Fondi pon un
progetto attraverso il quale abbiamo
chiesto a questi ragazzi a queste
ragazze di prendere i 17 gol dell'agenda
e di provare a portarli un po' più
vicino a scompattarli a metterli un po'
il locale magari ragionando sulla
propria scuola sulla propria comunità
soprattutto quartiere e chiedendo loro
che cosa si poteva fare per provare a
trovare qualche soluzione abbiamo fatto
così dalla novembre del 19 al maggio del
21 con una pandemia e un esame di
maturità in mezzo per alcuni di loro una
sorta di grande Parlamento in cui questi
ragazzi hanno per un bel periodo
affrontato tanti temi per esempio hanno
iniziato a lavorare intorno ai temi
della viabilità della sentire bene i
comuni
dell'accoglienza dei trasporti
dell'economia circolare delle energie
alternative e poi tutto il grande mondo
della questione Green che gli è molto
vicina
tutto questo lavoro dopo tutti questi
mesi a un certo punto è arrivato in
qualche modo a compimento i ragazzi si
sentivano pronti per fare le loro prime
proposte Allora via raccolta fondi per
trovare i soldi per mettere i pannelli
solari sopra gli istituti delle proprie
scuole poi ancora si sono inventati dei
giochi di società attraverso cui i nonni
e i nipoti potevano costruire insieme
dei percorsi per imparare a buttare la
raccolta differenziata e app che
mettevano insieme ragazzi di varie
scuole per cambiare i libri per i
vestiti in uno scambio equo e solidale
grandi battaglie hanno compiuto a scuola
per cercare di convincere magari qualche
preside ad aprire un mercatino solidale
nell'atrio o ad aprire un bagno a gender
Fluid dal quarto piano sempre in maniera
battagliera sono andati in comune a
discutere con i tecnici per capire
perché la zona sud a poche Fontanelle
così dobbiamo consumare un sacco di
plastica si sono inventati libri nostre
ricette con i quali hanno messo online
perché quello era consentito nulla di
più delle ricette in cui con gli scarti
del pranzo si faceva un menù completo La
sera dovete sentire che buoni che sono
le bucce di patate al forno hanno
immaginato e richiesta la propria scuola
dei percorsi alternativi Dove imparare
qualcosa del mondo del lavoro che
sentono loro molto lontano molto troppo
lontano dicono non sappiamo pagare una
bolletta Cosa volete che sappiamo
leggere un contratto di lavoro
e quando finalmente sono arrivato in
fondo eravamo pronti per raccontare
tutto questo alla città
Ognuno di loro si è preparato un Talk
credo siano fischiate molto le orecchie
agli amici del Ted le abbiamo citati
spesso e a un certo punto la città è
stata convocata e per raccontare tutto
questa è la città ci siamo immaginati
una cosa come questa
Avete presente gli speaker scorrere
quell'angolino a Londra dai park dove
chiunque può salire su un po' di dire la
propria Ecco noi abbiamo immaginato di
riempire la città di 500 cassette Perché
i nostri eroine le nostre eroine le
nostre eroi potessero salirci sopra e
raccontare ingaggiando con i passanti
delle belle discussioni sui temi che si
erano preparati
Eccolo qui il teatro che c'è ma non si
vede già perché sarò del mestiere però
per me quelle cassette sono dei piccoli
palcoscenici
e questi ragazzi hanno studiato perché
gli attori studiano hanno scritto il
loro intervento i loro monologhi e sono
andati di sopra convinti di riuscire a
cambiare la testa di chi li stava
ascoltando e cambiare perché no anche il
mondo sì lo so Questa non è la
definizione esatta di teatro lo capisco
Però sarebbe bello che fosse questa
ma ma ma insomma
che questa foto che vedete in realtà non
è di maggio del 21 e di molti mesi dopo
quando ho politico poetico ha Gemmato
degli spin off in altre parti d'Italia
Qui siamo a Sansepolcro con dei ragazzi
che hanno fatto un percorso molto più
breve già perché a maggio del 21 Bologna
era in zona gialla
nessuno poteva convocare gente a fare
nulla c'era il contingentamento cioè le
distanziamento
certo non si poteva fare un
assembramento e allora abbiamo potuto
fare un'unica cosa
questa una foto nulla di più
100 ragazzini
dall'alto ve la faccio vedere che hanno
trovato il modo di stare pochi secondi
sulle cassette e di fare un click due
anni di lavoro per un click non poteva
finire così
infatti
Loro complici nelle settimane precedenti
i tolc i monologhi si sono trasformati
in video racconti e ci siamo ritrovati
sul nostro tavolo quasi 400 racconti
fatti in video dai ragazzi dalle loro
camerette dai loro cortili del loro
balconi un lavoro incredibilmente bello
perché partito da loro dovevamo fare
solo una cosa a quel punto mettere tutto
su un sito questo
[Musica]
confesso che butto l'olio esausto nello
scarico della Vello confesso che oggetto
le cicche dal balcone aiuta l'ambiente è
sicuramente una delle cose più
importanti che dovremmo fare Riduci
ricicla riusa e ripeti produrre biogas
dalla fermentazione delle arance e
trasformarli in energia Ciao sono Elena
e voglio fare il falegname la mia è
un'età di dubbi e domande confiscati
bene alla mafia sapete come vivono le
persone incarcerate Adesso è veramente
arrivato il momento ad agire Perché
Bologna perché Bologna la mia città
[Musica]
Bologna Bologna la mia città quando
qualcosa la senti vicino la senti tu È
anche più facile impegnarsi no Se avete
voglia di vederli magari in versione
completa andate su un politico
poetico.it Seguite il percorso per gli
speakers Corner li trovate tutti e 400
a quest'età Questi ragazzi sono già
degli uomini delle donne fatte finite
sono già da che parte stare sono già che
musica ascoltare Come vestirsi però dopo
due anni di lavoro con loro ci sembra
davvero individuato 5 punti in comune
Diciamo che li accomunano un po' tutti
sia che vengano dal centro della
periferia sia che abbiano fatto un liceo
professionale sia che abbiano la media
del Lotto siano proprio bocciati 5
minimi comuni e denominatore cinque
tratti salienti che in qualche modo ne
vanno a comporre una sorta di carta
d'identità generazionale che nel bene o
nel male li ha segnate che sta segnando
gli insegnerà
il primo punto la loro passione
Ok sono pienamente su un divano a fare
PlayStation o Tik Tok però basta poco
per attivarli basta veramente poche
quando lo fanno lo fanno con una forza
un'energia noi sconosciuta lo facevano
già prima no vi ricordate i file del for
future Greta ma in generale molti di
loro fanno un po' di volontariato lo
fanno gettando il cuore rotto l'ostacolo
fanno in maniera preterintenzionale
magari in parrocchia o quelle
associazioni del territorio con gli
scout e anche chi non è così strutturato
comunque è sempre pronto a scendere in
piazza per protestare per qualche
diritto magari neanche suo e poi
diciamolo tutti a quell'età sono pronti
a fare attraversare la strada La
proverbiale vecchietta
2 la loro fragilità
questi due anni gli hanno annientati
atterriti
quel divano diventato sempre più largo
sempre più comodo sempre più fagocitante
di sguardi piano piano sono diventati va
qui e hanno iniziato a spegnersi subito
dopo le loro webcam
sono ragazzi che hanno molta difficoltà
a ripartire come se avessimo tolto due
anni di allenamento a una squadra di
professionisti i loro muscoli si sono un
po' atrofizzati hanno la forza per
ricominciare ma ci vorrà un po' di tempo
3 e 4
la loro indignazione e la loro rabbia
quando parlano di pace e Giustizia ci
sono due tesi che vengono fuori con
grande forza e ci stupiamo noi adulti
Perché vengono fuori da un gruppo tutto
sommato di ragazzi che stanno
affacciandosi adesso la loro diciamo
così età di cittadini consapevoli la
prima
è che per molti di loro allo stato dei
nostri diritti non interessa molto
la seconda è che molte occasioni allo
stato dei cittadini non interessa
proprio ora lo so per molti Spero non
per tantissimi c'è anche un fondo di
verità in questo però questi ragazzi a
17 anni ci stanno dicendo che le
istituzioni per loro sono già nemiche o
non servono tutte le istituzioni
il comune lo stato ma anche la famiglia
la scuola sono arrabbiati c'è poco da
fare nei loro racconti ci sono
riferimenti a George Floyd
a Genova anche se non erano nati
azaki a regeni parlano di mafia di
collusione hanno questa opinione qui e
per noi è stato difficile dirgli che
certo hanno anche ragione sotto certi
punti di vista ma non bisogna fare
diagnosi si può provare a essere proprio
noi la parte nuova che interviene per
cambiare il sistema a mente raccontavamo
ste cose al nord c'era un assessore che
sparava nelle piazze qui da queste parti
non carcere a Santa Maria Capua Vetere
succedevano altri fatti è complesso
fanno recuperati 5 hanno paura
126 progetti quasi un terzo del totale
parlano di soprusi parlano
di situazioni dove il diritto è legato
hanno paura tutti a quell'età e fa male
la paura quell'età hanno paura le
ragazze di uscire di casa di essere
molestate orientate uccise hanno paura
di non trovare un lavoro o di non
trovare una famiglia o di trovare un
lavoro e quindi non potessi fare una
famiglia o trovarsi una famiglia e
quindi esclude la possibilità a lavorare
hanno paura di trovarlo Finalmente un
lavoro che diventa Però quel Ring
quotidiano dove ogni giorno devono
salire e affermarsi a cominciare dalle
questioni salariali e non solo hanno
paura di trovarla alla fine
un principe azzurro Ma che non
assomiglia a quello che leggevano nei
romanzi Rosa ma che sia un film
dell'orrore che comincia Quando chiudono
la doppia mandata il portone di casa ma
la paura non è una questione solo di
genere perché hanno paura tutti quei
ragazzi e quelle ragazze con problemi
con fragilità che si ritrovano di fronte
a barriere non solo architettoniche ma
culturali sociali e loro si sentiranno
sempre cittadini in serie B hanno paura
tutte le persone afferenti al mondo lgbt
qua il plus
che sono oggetto di un nodo antico
tavico anche un po' antistorico che
ancora più grave quando arriva
all'interno dalle famiglie No hanno
paura tutti quei ragazzi e quelle
ragazze e quei tratti somatici ci
ricordano che forse vengono da
provenienza e altre perché sanno che
continueranno a essere guardati male
quando entreranno dentro a un negozio e
La proverbiale vecchiatina continuerà a
tirare a sé la borsa quando saliranno
sull'autobus
la paura ora fa male quel fa male tanto
però non ci deve stupire per esempio che
la il suicidio la seconda causa di morte
tra i ragazzi tra i 10 e i 25 anni che
l'autolesionismo riguarda il 20% di loro
e che è pronto soccorso delle grandi
città sono sempre più frequentati da
ragazzini di 12 anni come ti dico
di questi ragazzi il politico poetico ha
provato a trovare un'azione per non
lasciarli fuori dalla fotografia di
questa generazione che volevamo fare e
l'ho fatto attraverso uno spettacolo in
realtà virtuale
una roba un po' strana lo ammetto ma
dove il visore non è la moda del momento
questo progetto è nato prima della
pandemia ma è lo strumento attraverso
cui letteralmente noi adulti possiamo
essere catapultati dentro queste storie
di queste ragazze possiamo letteralmente
guardare quei loro occhi è letteralmente
toccare con le loro mani è uno
spettacolo doloroso uno spettacolo duro
cattivo
Ma si sa
vanno fatte queste cose non ve lo posso
parlare di più ve ne parlo magari
un'altra volta
ora che cosa ci rimane di tutto questo
dopo in altri due anni di lavoro Beh
intanto che c'è venuta voglia di farne
un altro troveremo a farlo in chiave
Europea andando magari con la nostra
cassetta su a Bruxelles
ma intanto quello che abbiamo capito che
queste ragazze sono belli e belle e
belli con l'asterisco e belcolaio
rovesciata sono liquidi per natura per
elezione Divina sono diversi felici di
esserlo perché per loro la diversità è
un valore sono tutto quello che avremmo
potuto essere noi alla loro età ma lo
siamo diventati molto più tardi per loro
non esistono i confini il mondo è casa
Vorrebbero abitarlo tutto sono persone
che amano ascoltare che di solito non
giudicano in scialla Bella zio
sono capaci di grandi slanci sui diritti
e sull'ambiente sanno che non c'è un
piano B
Ora basta un pallone e un bel sedere per
ritornare su quel divano Ma come abbiamo
detto
quando serve sanno salvare di nuovo
inseguire il sogno giusto
In conclusione sono sicuramente il
nostro miglior antidoto la nostra
migliore chance per puntare ad avere
davvero un futuro più inclusivo più
attento e più giusto dobbiamo solo
aiutarli a sopravvivere ai loro 16 anni
Grazie
[Applauso]